michael myers is back with a brand new
sequel to the original Halloween movie
that seems Laurie Strode face a
tormentor and a thrilling showdown
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm breaking down
everything you need to know about the
ending of the new Halloween movie
including that WTF twist and crucial
details you might have missed plus I'll
explain my theory about the mask and the
role of Laurie's granddaughter in the
next sequel make sure you watch till the
end for some bonus Easter eggs so tap
the bell and also leave me a comment
about the movie for a chance to win one
of these cool Halloween merch packs
spoilers ahead for Halloween 2018 plus
other movies in the franchise the climax
of the new Halloween movie sees Michael
Myers battle three generations of strode
women in an epic showdown Laurie's been
waiting years for this moment and she's
fortified and booby-trapped the house to
the max Michael does break his way in
though and during the final
confrontation we get a replay in Reverse
at the final moments of the first
Halloween movie as this time it's Laurie
not Michael who goes over the balcony
and then disappears Laurie's daughter
Karen then attracts Michael's attention
with her cries for help
leading him to believe she'll be an easy
next victim but it turns out to be a
trap basically the hunter has now become
the hunted as the strobes have him
cornered the final trap is then sprung
as a strode start to fill the safe room
with gas after which Laurie lights at
her Halloween fans will notice
similarities between this scene and how
dr. Loomis set Michael on fire in a
hospital room full of leaking oxygen
canisters in Halloween 2 the three women
flee the burning house and have picked
up by a passing truck a very quick shot
inside the basement shows it on fire
that we can't see if Michaels there any
longer what we do here though is a light
breathing sound which director David
Gordon Green er said is Allison the
movie ends with a close-up of the
granddaughter still gripping the kitchen
knife which she used earlier against
Michael during their escape and if you
stay all the way through the credits
there isn't an actual post-credit scene
but you do hear what seems to be Michael
breathing similar to how you hear penny
wise as maniacal laugh at the end of the
credits and it chapter one which in my
mind implies that Michael is still alive
ending the movie with the sound of
Alison and Michael's breathing is a
director
how the first movie ended and as we know
Michael was still alive and at large
then the second Halloween movie did
attempt to establish that fire was the
only thing that would eventually kill
Michael but that idea was tossed out
when he returned in Halloween for
curiously this new film features a tape
of dr. Loomis saying that Michael needs
to be terminated with Loomis at the time
insisting he should be there to make
sure Michael's vitals are no longer
functioning and to incinerate the body
still it's been reported that blunt
House already working on a script for a
sequel to this movie which is hardly
surprising given how much money it looks
set to make at the box office
in many ways this Halloween movie feels
like an updated version of the 1978
Halloween even if it is laden with
Easter eggs and callbacks to many of the
other movies in the franchise in this
sequel Laurie has reclaimed the
narrative switching the role of predator
and prey by hunting Michael herself
tracking him trapping him and seemingly
in her eyes killing him there was a hint
at this role reversal between Laurie and
Michael early on in the film when
Allison and her boyfriend did a gender
swap cosplay of Bonnie and Clyde at a
Halloween party and that little moment
was also one of many parallels drawn in
the film between Allison and her
grandmother it's also interesting that
in this film we have three generations
of Strode women who've survived Michael
and there's an intriguing detail and the
ending that I think means Laurie's
granddaughter will actually be the key
to the next sequel the final shot of
Alison still holding the knife she used
against Michael feels like a deliberate
callback to the ending of Halloween for
the return of Michael Myers in that
movie which now exists in a separate
timeline Laurie's daughter Jamie ended
up making a kind of psychic connection
to Michael Myers when she touched his
hand at one point in the film through
that connection Jamie took on some of
Michael's evil instincts and ended up
stabbing her foster mother holding the
weapon she used as a movie finished
remember that in this new film Alison
came into close contact with Michael
when she was trapped with him in the
back of the police car
she also witnessed several horrific
murders her father's been killed and
after fleeing Michael she ended up
traumatized in the middle of Laurie
shooting range
surrounded by creepy bullet-ridden
mannequins although Alison obviously
survived I wonder
she might end up suffering from similar
PTSD to Lori the question is will
Allison get the psychological help that
she needs to deal with everything that's
happened to her unlike Lori in the
original films so there's a possible
connection between Allison and Michael
which could be explored in a sequel with
actress and the matichek taking the lead
role rather than Jamie Lee Curtis okay
so let's talk about that contentious
twist in the third act where dr. Sartain
or the new Loomis as Marie called him
stopped sheriff Hawkins from shooting
Michael by stabbing the officer with a
pen blade which point he not only became
a killer himself but even took on the
identity of Michael Myers donning his
mask this moment was foreshadowed
earlier in the film when sautéing told
Lori how Hawkins had stopped Loomis from
killing Michael Myers 40 years ago this
time around though the roles of the
psychiatrist and the sheriff have been
reversed with dr. Sartain stopping
sheriff Hawkins from killing Michael on
the surface or tane is similar to Loomis
who in this version of Halloween has
passed away off screen like Loomis
Sartain is obsessed with his patient
Michael however his ideas about the
killer are basically the complete
opposite of Loomis's Sartain wants to
explore and understand what makes
Michael tick in his desperate to see him
reunited with Laurie presumably so he
can observe what happens the character
of Sartain has proved polarizing among
fans and critics with some complaining
his too cartoonish and his performances
OTT although the idea of a deranged
psychiatrist who wants to become like
Michael is rather interesting I think
the problem is that the character of dr.
Sartain might feel jarring to some fans
who consider him a replacement for dr.
Loomis a much-loved character from the
franchise who couldn't return in person
because actor Donald Pleasence has long
since passed away but in reality the
real dr. Loomis of this Halloween movie
is Laurie Strode
after all Laurie knows Michael better
than anyone and she and Lewis were both
there that fateful night in 1978 also
just like Loomis Laurie's warnings about
Michael aren't often taken with the
degree of seriousness they should be so
the real message was supposed to get
from both Sartain and the podcasters
obsession is that it's actually useless
to try to understand why Michael Maia
does what he does as Laurie herself says
there's nothing new to learn there are
no new insights or discoveries ever
since the first film many fans have
questioned Michaels motivation
themselves and it's something the
franchise has attempted to answer in its
myriad of sequels and ever-increasing
mythology over the years but this
Halloween movie says we should forget
about all that and just listen to Loomis
and Laurie's view of Michael in other
words he's basically the embodiment of
pure evil indeed as director David
Gordon greener said in our version of
the story as in John Carpenter's Michael
is an essence he's not a character
there's no arc he's shape speaking of
which given Michael's victims and mainly
random then perhaps it could also be
possible for the person under the mask
to be random too so even though the film
teases that Michael could still be alive
with a shot of an empty burning basement
and what sounds like he's breathing at
the very end what if Michael really is
dead the real twist then could be that
the Michael Myers legend lives on
through copycat killers who take up his
masked identity as doctor sautéeing
briefly did in this film remember for
example that we don't know for sure if
the police managed to recapture all
those patients who escaped from the bus
with Michael because this Halloween
movie replaces the original sequel
Halloween to the reveal in that film of
Michael and Laurie being siblings has
been discarded 1981's Halloween two
established the idea that Michael was
trying to kill Laurie because she was
his sister he'd already killed his other
sister Judas at the beginning in the
first film and after escaping he wanted
to finish the job and kill Laurie as
well that brother-sister relationship
became the basis for Michael's
motivations in various Halloween movies
for example Halloween 4 where he decided
to go after Laurie's daughter this new
story abandons all the continuity from
those other films which means that in
this new timeline Michael's obsession
with Laurie is simply random and it was
just her bad luck that she wandered up
to the old Myers house at the moment he
was standing inside looking out with
Michael's family connection to Laurie
gone it actually makes him a much
scarier villain and that fact is
acknowledged in a very meta moment in
the movie where Alison tells her friends
that Michael and Laurie being siblings
was just a lie the townspeople made up
to make themselves feel better
but the terrifying babysitter murders in
this Halloween movie Michael doesn't
appear to have any particular motivation
as to who he targets and he really does
fulfill his homicidal instinct with the
exception of holding back from killing a
baby this Michael seems to kill whoever
he feels like in his path everyone from
gas station attendants to
sandwich-making mothers and in a rather
shocking move we even see him murder a
young boy though the director
deliberately blurs the shot somewhat
when Laurie calls him the shape at one
point in the movie it's not only a
reference to how Michael Myers was
credited in the first film it's also an
acknowledgement the kind of faceless
violence the character represents he's a
remorseless brutal killing machine with
no real humanity and that lack of
humanity is alluded to throughout the
film with characters referring to
Michael variously as it this thing or
property of the state and during his
final confrontation with Laurie he hides
among her mannequins as he's just
another soulless entity Halloween 2018
is of course stacked with Easter eggs
and callbacks to all the other films but
there are some particularly interesting
details I noticed that really adds some
extra meaning to the movie this sequel
pays a march to the orange-coloured
opening credits and jack-o'-lantern of
the original film but there's a clever
riff on them this time though as a
decomposed pumpkin slowly comes back to
life over the course of the credits
which is a nice metaphor for this film's
rebirth of the Halloween franchise after
what many would say are years of it
slowly rotting away and did you notice
that sheriff Hawkins was playing a Back
to the Future game when he got a call
about the bus crash like Laurie in the
new timeline Hawkins was there in 1978
and actually stopped dr. Loomis killing
Michael something he seems to regret and
he tries to make up for what happened
that night by mowing Michael down with
his police car all these years later
which is also an Easter Egg to how
deputy Ramsey crashed into been trauma
in Halloween too while he was wearing a
mask and if you're curious about why
Karyn was a Christmas sweater in the
movie when it's Halloween
remember when Alison's friends told her
her grandmother Laurie should skip
Halloween and just put up a Christmas
tree
well the real meaning of Karin's festive
jumper is to symbolize how she's
rejecting her mother's paranoia and
Halloween's associations with terrible
personal tragedies in her family
effectively
she wants to skip over or block out
Halloween and jump forward instead to a
happier holiday season
at the end of this film the room where
Laurie falls out the window is an exact
rebuild of the bedroom from the original
movies finale it wasn't made to use for
the end of this movie originally but was
actually built for a completely
different purpose which I'll discuss in
my deleted scenes video shortly however
an unintended consequence of using the
same set for the final sequence in the
new movie is that it subtly adds to the
feeling that Laurie has never been able
to shake off her past since the events
of 1978 so what was your favorite moment
in the new Halloween movie and do you
have any theories about Michael Myers or
Alison returning in a sequel let me know
what you think in the comments below and
remember to subscribe for a chance to
win one of these cool Halloween merch
packs tapleft to check out the secret
truth about Michael Myers in Halloween
2018 or tap right for another video
you're sure to like if you enjoyed this
I really appreciate a thumbs up and a
share thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers